we're talking about tattoos I'm not
opposed to Tooting my own horn and
that's not a euphemism for something
that you needed to cut out of this
either if you go on the YouTube you can
catch them my name is Jeff Goldblum and
I'm gonna look at some tattoos I've
specifically said don't show me before
we do this so this is all gonna be a
spontaneous surprise to me and you'll
see my natural reaction as I see these
pictures what the heck is this I've
never seen this perform my life nor do I
know this shot and I suspect it's it's a
mock-up ahh I know I don't like to wear
it now a Tattersall shirt was that
Tattersall shirt
I've strong feelings about fashion as
you may or may not know and what's this
chain this sort of rappers chain around
my neck I don't know what they're
getting at there but I like its
obtuseness it's uh and it's darkness I
give it ten Goldblum's out of a possible
ten golems a lovely tattoo of myself
from the first Jurassic Park look at the
rendering look at that nice manly Adam's
apple and my feathery hair hey I see
they've they've rendered some kind of
lovely vein there that I've never
noticed myself have my skin is so
translucent that it shows those lovely
veins but yeah it's nice for these
purposes well anyway there's a firm
jawline and everything's just fine and
dandy
and now the tone changes entirely
visually backwards in the in the window
at this establishment jurassic pizza
I've never known such a place I don't
know if a place exists but I love pizza
of interest to nobody necessarily I am
feeding a nice piece of hot pizza to a
velociraptor of course it it it's a
whimsical representation of the
relationship that I would have with a
velociraptor because those things as we
know from the movies are fearsome you
don't want to get near those things
well look at this picture now this is a
manly arm I may be wrong you know I
played a detective on television and so
I noticed things that others may not it
was for much shoot that I did and I'm
doing something coy with my lip and my
finger I may have done some shaking with
our lovely crews so I don't exactly put
my finger in my mouth right now and it
looks like that but that's what mr.
Goldblum has there this looks like a
lady or man I don't know with a very
shapely lovely leg the color of skin
like a freshly peeled Apple very very
beautiful now this is me I know this
shot well this is from a real shot that
I took and you know was was taken while
I was in Australia don't ask me I won't
bore you with the details of how I wound
up in well you know I wasn't a australia
shooting that thora movie that's what I
was doing in Australia anyway I had this
food truck and I was giving out
sandwiches and somebody took a
delightful picture of me a photograph
which I like I have it on my Instagram
I've seen it and I've saved it now I've
never seen this configuration imagining
that it's a lady I think it is because
we see we're looking at we can see the
lovely upper thigh is a beautiful three
shot really with me and the great Sam
Neill as Alan Grant and there's of
course our friend the velociraptor and
there is some like some centerpiece that
you'd have you know at Thanksgiving I've
never seen this for heaven's sakes this
is a cartoony wonderful wonderful thing
on somebody's what kind of limb is that
so fleshy fleshy appendage which has a
green cartoony looks like a t-rex with
some glasses on hey what's that mean
life it includes my hemming and hawing
life finds away says I and it looks like
he's fashioned his hair or gotten a
toupee and tried to recreate my hair
well that is pretty clever 10 Goldblum's
out of a bus
ten Gophers almost everybody gets a
perfect score really you'll find look at
that what's going on there I wish I were
looking at that and eating a nice plate
of huevos rancheros chips and salsa and
a nice margarita mmm not a hot day like
this is wouldn't that be good my lips
are full in a way that mine aren't full
exactly but nothing wrong with that and
my eyes look even behind those tinted
frames a little uh you know we're er
kind of confused but that's okay I'm in
shock
this is very very beautiful this comes
an image that has been photo is
photographed when I took to the red
carpet believe it or not in my big giant
Tom Ford bowtie and a nice Tom Ford
white dinner jacket you get something
like that
and that you pay a nice you know you pay
something for that I've never seen this
before of course he's got some sandals
on you have to be a special kind of
adult man if you want to show your feet
in public and wear a sandal and I like
to see a nice woman's foot I think they
get a little more leeway men and keep it
at home unless you have a lovely lovely
foot this we're not seeing so he may
have a lovely foot it's from Life
Aquatic the great director Wes Anderson
we did a 12 or 13 years ago now and he
said and I've got my own pink scarf that
scarf even though this is rendered in
black and white that's a light a very
pale pink scarf and then there's a white
lab coat that they made me because I'm
supposed to be a fancy successful
oceanographer
[Music]
very beautiful oh I know what the liquid
is I was thinking when they put a
cocktail in the middle of this thing for
the tattoo itself is a weird affair
there's much foliage
there's once again our very frightening
Velociraptor with many teeth for
heaven's sakes the available they've
left me alone and the t-rex is on its
way well how do I know because the glass
of water rare rare rare oh boy and I say
my line I'm fairly alarmed here alarmed
here this is a heck of a an
extrapolation and artistics
extrapolation of my face just made me
look Spanish like a bullfighter or
something with with dark brooding eyes
and it doesn't worry me at all that the
that mr. velociraptor is right over my
head because I fear nothing that's the
kind of guy that I am well it also gets
ten out of ten gold looms and thank you
for watching tattoo tour or why'd you go
and jelly yourself up like that with me
Jeff Jeff Goldblum